Maya: Thanks, everyone. The goal today is to decide what ships in the July product release and what moves into the backlog.
Luis: Support has seen repeated requests for bulk transcript upload. Teams with weekly department meetings do not want to upload files one by one.
Priya: Engineering can build bulk upload if we limit the first version to ten files at a time and reuse the existing validation rules for file type and size.
Jon: From the sales side, citation confidence is a stronger demo moment than bulk upload. Buyers keep asking whether the answer is traceable to the source transcript.
Maya: Let's make citation confidence the release headline. Bulk upload can be the second feature if engineering capacity holds.
Priya: Decision noted. July release priority one is citation confidence. Priority two is bulk upload behind a feature flag.
Luis: I will write the support examples for low-confidence answers by Friday. Those examples should include vague questions and missing-context cases.
Jon: I will update the demo script so it asks, "What did we decide about onboarding?" and then opens the source drawer.
Maya: Action items are Luis on support examples, Jon on the demo script, and Priya on the citation confidence implementation plan.
Priya: Risk is embedding cost during large uploads. We should add a warning before upload if the file set is likely to be expensive.
Maya: Good call. Cost warning is not required for July launch, but it should be tracked as a follow-up.
Luis: No blockers from support. I will also prepare three sample transcripts that are safe for public demos.
Maya: Final recap: ship citation confidence first, keep bulk upload behind a flag, and track cost warnings as a follow-up.